hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast rapid learning for precision
oncology I'm Christina dilma
collaboration I'll be your moderator for
today's event today's educational
seminars presented by muttering the
leading scientific social networking
website and provider of virtual events
and webinars advancing scientific
collaboration and learning we have a few
important announcements before we begin
this webcast is designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to ask
questions during the event you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window we're
trying to enter as many questions as we
can you can enlarge the side window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the side window if
you have any technical problems viewing
or hearing this presentation please
click on the support button at the top
right of your presentation window or
submit your problem two degree in human
a button on the lower this is an
educational webinar in the stoppers free
continuing education credits after the
webinar is over please click on the CTE
button located in the bottom left hand
corner of your web page and follow the
process of obtaining your credit I would
now like to introduce today's speaker
dr. Marty tenenbaum dr. Marty Tannenbaum
is a renowned computer scientist
internet entrepreneur and cancer warrior
gives the founder and chairman of quick
answers common a non profit network of
physicians scientists and patients that
newsweek dubbed the linkedin of cancer
he began his career in artificial
intelligence and machine learning
leading elite research groups at fri
international informers a limited later
has an Internet commerce pioneers he
founded or co-founded five successful
startups dr. tenenbaum is a fellow and
former board members of the association
of the advancement of artificial
intelligence a former director of the
public library of science plus a farmer
board member
as patients like me he is also a former
consulting professor of computer science
at Stanford and currently serves as a
director of Commerce nuts and efficient
finance dr. Tannenbaum holds BS and ms
degrees in electrical engineering from
MIT and the PhD from Stanford and has
received numerous awards for him work as
a patient advocate I would now like to
turn the presentation over to dr. Marty
Tennyson there's a kind of odd Thank You
kushina and good afternoon everybody
thank you for joining us today I'm going
to talk about some of the challenges and
precision oncology in the lab where
unique perspective my background as a
computer scientist internet entrepreneur
and cancer survivor these challenges
have as much to do with the information
and knowledge place the informatics of
what's going on as they do about the
traditional science and medicine I'm
going to talk about what I'm doing that
to try to address these challenges in
the context of cancer commons among
profit organization which things
together physicians patients and
researchers in the rapid learning
community and will first talk about
solution for their aim directly at
helping today's patients try to find
solutions to their account welcome for
two in part 3 i'll talk about a future
vision and it's not on far future the
near future may begin the next six
months to a year will be there so that
we can talk about not just learning on
behalf of not just doing something to
help an individual patient but trying to
drive community learning across the
entire community so that we learn from
one type what we learn from one patient
and the useful immediately to help the
next station I will then adjust some
systemic roadblocks that are necessary
in order to be able to realize this
vision and also what's going good some
takes to solve a pillbox and that's
going to require a collective action on
the part of all of us and finally some
takeaways which
hopefully we'll provide some new
perspectives to everybody in terms of
size whether you're on the informatics
side or the medicine side on what we
need to do in order to be able to
describe they realize the promise of
vision oncology 17 years ago I was
diagnosed with melanoma metastatic liver
which is a wicked prognosis and wicked
diseases I her prognosis and frankly I
didn't know what to do I went to a few
doctors and they told me that things are
not good it wasn't much Desai I wasn't
willing to take that for an answer so i
expanded my search and in the end with
the help of some friends at the National
Pension speak I probably talked to a
couple of dozen doctors and most of them
agreed on only one place which was
that's the prognosis is dire I was given
9 to 12 months but everyone said
especially the researchers and if you
had one thing to try God he'll marry
wanted to try this or that and everyone
he was talking about the thing that they
will be searching but there was no data
to help me as a patient try to make an
informed decision and that was a
nightmare in the end I trusted my gut
and get my wife on a clinical trial
which ultimately fell but it's help some
patients I was happened to be fortunate
enough to be an exceptional responder
and I'm alive today and I made a vow at
that point that I would as soon as I got
my health back news my experience as a
computer scientist an eminent
entrepreneurs to try to do something
about solving the problem of how to help
patients make the right decision fast
forward in or 17 years and things
haven't changed all that not shown
patient gets diagnosed they go home the
first thing they did was controlled by
Google and what they get is like you can
read the frontier it says 1.7 million
results in point 29 seconds and one long
learning to list and that's not too
helpful
because the first you know hundred pages
of the scuffs mostly cancer 101 in kind
of generalities but what I can do to
help yourself this is wearing mom who
saved my life and the paper who assisted
saved my life which was literally on
about the five thousand scream of a
google search and the only way one could
have found it is that someone told me
but don Morton had something that might
be helpful to me and go look for it and
what's even more frustrating is this
paper which was written about 14 years
later and published posthumously again
2014 which my case is included is one of
the case studies were discovered and it
said that you know if you have medicine
olan olan ecstatic deliver and it's the
cancer can be excised the remote
effectively as I interesting thing to
try along with some kind of
immunotherapy will likely remain itself
this is the situation that exists in
medical literature today but I guess I
guess the point I want to make it that
although this paper was there 14 years
later retrospective it's still very
difficult to find because done been
publishing in nature or sell a science
epub worse than the annals of surgery
and that's not highly index google is
not a good way to find needles and I set
that we're looking at here is a scene of
the plenary session of the astral
meeting if any if you have been there
you'll realize that what you're looking
at is a very small construction of the
nudist 10,000 people of experiment if
you know can Pan the camera back out
this these local people will go on as
far as the eye can see and what's
interesting is that anything that's
discussed on the stage with a knife
still meeting for the most part is going
to be clean 25 years out of date
compared to what the people on the stage
the sudden privately in terms of liquor
you know thinking at the cutting edge
and it kind of has to be this way
because when asked those two life-sized
things
the substantial body of evidence that's
going to create over a number of years
because that well this is no valid in
sight yep if I'm a patient who's dying i
would like to know what's happening at
the moment at the cutting edge most
cutting-edge places what's in the heads
of League and the extras now that's the
first smile problem the last mile
problem is once this thing has been once
the experts have said where's
information even if it is three or five
years out of date was going to take
another decade or more for this
information to confuse asking the front
lines of care were a patient being
treated say in West Virginia and what's
the docking in the room at the time this
happened there unless he was fortunate
enough to see it in a news release or
something like that because the very
next dog you know week another thousand
is so campus capers are going to get
published so we have both the first mile
problem of how to get information out of
the heads of the experts and the last
mile problem of getting that information
to the place where it's needed at the
time experiences it's not buried under a
tsunami of things with a less relevant
soon to the patient this has real
consequences and the consequences are
measured most immediately in terms of
the variations and treatment and
outcomes across patient in different
institution from different geographies
to the left what what we're seeing is a
comparison of five-year survival for
early one cancer patients at a community
hospital and a nearby Comprehensive
Cancer Center and this was a few years
old and perhaps the variation has
reduced somewhat but the point is that
this stuff that variation in care varies
widely and falls off very quickly as one
moves from the centers of knowledge
outing for the community and then
especially into the disadvantaged
communities the world communities from
the third world community and it's find
about rageous I think that this will
happen in the Internet age but
nonetheless is a substantial number of
life Thursday
on the right you see a similar
comparison across seven Western European
countries this was from mag and the way
that's 2015 very detailed survey of by
outcomes and you might notice that this
is a five year survival for all cancers
across leads from countries including
the number with sixty-five percent in
the UK there's only fifty percent and
these countries more or less have access
to the same knowledge and I'm jugs in
principle nonetheless with a thirty
percent difference and given how many
cancer patients are involved across all
these countries you're talking about
hundreds of thousands of life so what
can we do about that well the what we
can do is challenging because in the
last 17 years things have gotten more
difficult not easier there's certainly a
lot more choices of promising therapy to
the patient and the doctor can
considered but we now thanks to the
genome projects and progress in cancer
biology understand that many many
cancers are different from each other
potentially every cancer every patient
because smoke like would generate a
molecularly different at some level
whether that's funny you know critical
and not paying for the treatment remains
to be seen we now have hundreds of good
therapy many targeted therapies and we
know that these drugs have to get recent
combination the problem is is when you
have combinations of Huntington drugs
taken in you know four or five at a time
not necessarily in parallel but over the
course of treatment over the course of a
regimen there's a lot of the tens of
thousands of plausible combinations of
easing excessive and given that
potentially every cancer is unique
there's kind of no way that you can test
to find optimal combinations of
therapies within the context of
randomized trials it does not perform
given to these trial
take hundreds to thousands of patients
each and take five to ten years there's
just no way to systematically explore
their face I am as a result i'm going to
make a fairly bold statement that
there's no one who can confidently say
they know the optimal ways to treat any
campus and as an example i will point at
the fact that in the last five years or
so there have been something like 11 new
melanoma indications within the nucleus
by the fda in the united states and we
know that these therapies and need to be
used in combination and if you think
about it ok so 11 things maybe there's
four more or five more older therapies
that are treatments including surgery
and radiation and various kinds of
chemotherapy that are used on melanoma
patient so maybe 15 things have taken a
half a dozen at a time if you remember
from your high school combinatorial
mathematics tens of thousands of things
to say nothing about what what are these
things should be given in and when you
should start and stop them which means
when they should be overlap and what
does those things should be and all of
those things being unique to each
individual so I reveal one step further
and say not only there's no one mode a
optimal way to keep any melanoma or any
cancer for that matter but no one even
variously optimal way to find out and
that's because people are completely
reliant on these randomized trials with
a jug very seldom tested to take a head
or in all of the rational combinations
that are can be done and I give you rug
you know a pictorial way to thinking
about the combinatorics here on the left
is the way the council used to be say 30
40 years ago at the beginning them the
war of cancer cancer was a relatively
simple I'll call with a 10 by 10 disease
where along the bottom are the extended
Jordan based phenotypes long dress so on
and so forth and there are you know
order of a
so standardized chemotherapies that were
often used over and over again with
minor modification each of these so we
have you know 10 by 10 cells 100 cells
about a million patients a year in the
US who might be in principle able to
benefit from clinical trials so that's
about 100 boxes and million patients so
you've got you know 10,000 patients per
box which is plenty to be able to run
trial but now in 2017 we have you know
millions of molecular features so
essentially every chance of being unique
and ten thousands of tens of thousands
of rational combinations of drugs so the
number of patients per experimental cell
here is epsilon 40 so not only is your
very difficult to think about finding
out optimal regimen with clinical trials
as we've known them but for anyone
because cancer is a big data problem the
dimensionality of this space is so high
compared to the number of patients that
I think it would be more correct to say
it's a fact eight a problem and by that
I mean there are many many columns of
data that you can get for a given
patients giving their all their own
makeda and so forth but very few rows in
the table this cannot that many patients
who are available success in any of
these boxes so what can we do in the
absence of the kind of data within
either study and this is one of my
favorite folks from Larry Martin was one
of my board members should count your
comment Larry says that you know when
the absence of the thin of the clinical
studies the best thing that you can do
is through Caffrey insights and
intuitions and experience of our best
commissions and in the AI field there
was one of the founders in sales for
Simon & noble laureate used to play
something similar he said you know
follow the experts because they know
what's going on so even in the absence
of data explore the case that there are
superb physicians who are out there at
the leading edge with desperate patients
trying all kinds of things every day off
label and what year you see here is a
picture of the gossip
oh gee who wrote this wonderful enter of
all maladies but he's with one of these
patients and we wrote more recently an
article called the improvisational
oncologist which was a Sunday near Times
article about a year ago so it really is
very lucky to have a master like dr.
mukajee but what is being discussed here
is going to basically say in that room
she may have a solution it may help her
and it's I it happened to work dr.
mukajee will no doubt try to come up
with like cake series of a number of
patients or perhaps run a clinical trial
and if this can be replicated widely
enough to publish otherwise the learning
will get lots of the world a similar
situation occurs with molecular tumor
board where the most challenging cases
are discussed by the best doctors at the
best institution and which is an ideal
situation where one can find out three
years ahead of westland was before the
vasco what's going on because these docs
are actively discussing the cases but no
one for buying large has captured that
knowledge in a form that can do other
people as much good as possible and by
that i mean not just what
recommendations come out which probably
will go into the clinical record of the
patients at least but the rationale for
that decision and equally important what
the hypotheses who have concluded and
rejected and what were the reasons for
rejecting those because sometimes we may
have to go back and reconsider those
zombies expectation didn't respond is
expected and so where are these you know
every way there's thousands of
experiments that go on oncology offices
and say clean up in dis captured and i
can tell you where the tide was ever in
a position where I didn't you know had
another recurrence and needed to deal
with her I would want my daughter to
know what everybody in this room knows
not just what particular person knows
would understand and so that's the
challenge that I took on in the garden
cancer common
which brings me to the second part of
the tox build and can be quickly
together but cancer comment is what it
says on how we're using it initially
feeling health individual patient treat
their disease and use what we learn from
helping one patient to help many others
so cancer comments in what can be called
the rapid learning community for cancer
what we do is try to help each
individual patients are paying the best
possible outcome for that patient and
this can include an arbitrary amount of
research done on behalf of that patient
by members of our community both
scientists as well as physicians start
with the model then treat the patient
analyze the results and that the patient
didn't respond as expected to go back
and try to understand life ideally team
locates post-treatment biopsy to
understand if we sarah p actually reach
the similar as it did did bind to the
right targets that have the right effect
and if it didn't work as expected to go
back to the doctors and the scientists
and say what did we not understand
either about the person's cancer or
about the mechanisms of action of that
drug and by the way you don't have five
years to solve this problem you're not
clearly because the patient of cell
therapy and they'll be coming back and
we need to have a plan B at that point
so again help the patient get the best
outcome learn as much as possible and
then disseminate what you learn as
rapidly as possible not wait two years
to do this come out in the form of
publication not that we want to get rid
of formal publication planning means we
want to admit them with a real-time
communication channel that can be used
to drive real time limit this vision has
attracted some amazing people on our
cancer from and forth and advisory
boards and this just about I recognize
tourism showing in this picture but i'll
point out they include the former
editor-in-chief of both the german
the AMA in the science George limburg
and Dom Kennedy they improved the
directory service on four or five cancer
centers and some amazing positions and
patient advocates and computational
biologist Don can be said what motivated
him inside in particular which is that
the failure of putting patients at the
front ended its remarkable experiment
where we're trying to learn as much as
possible from from each patient's we
might verify this by saying that a
clinical trial of impatience is really
basically end end of one study if we can
figure out how to exploit the learning
to come out of each of those patients as
well as we specifically delphos them out
as a whole setting suddenly can make
projects and that's a lot faster and a
green subway station so going from
vision submission we've seen our mission
as being a multi-channel broker of
insight so the insights can come from
many places along the bottom of this
slide and we're capturing them and then
letting those insights outfield the
front lines where they're needed as
rapidly as possible but then closing the
learning rule by finding out from those
people who are using them what those
insights are can be validated either in
the lab or in the clinic and closing
closing that loops back on itself so
that we can validate and make sure
everybody who needs to know what it is
in fact so we are right but we're
focusing specifically on clinically
actionable insights from two unique
sources namely case reports end of one
case reports from individual physicians
who are experimenting the gulf level
drug and similar types of nf1
experiments that are being done in the
context of human voice we are very much
interested in capturing clinical
insights from all the other sources as
well but there's lots of people
that's issues including Google in Watson
and so we're going to focus on trying to
get this knowledge we were cutting edge
knows the most recent knowledge out of
the heads of the experts who are sitting
and getting it specifically to the
patients and physicians who need that to
act on it and then closing to the back
in order to do this we were building a
network of physicians and scientists and
patients which means weeks of the link
in the campus and with this network
we're inviting patients who are facing
challenging cases basically they've
exhausted for the most part exhausted
the standard of care to come to us with
their cases we will then send those
cases so we will the clearing us so that
patients do not talk directly to the
expo so we forward the cases p with
other than extras and where appropriate
were necessary convene a panel of
experts and offensive actions in the
board discuss the case and get the
answer back to the patient but we're
than that we then tips what we learn
from this one patients and and
formulated in a way that can be rapidly
confirmed by other patients and the
physicians treating them so that what we
can do a not afford to do a fair amount
of research to help one patient with the
view that will be due to health one
patient might have four hundred others
or a thousand of depending on you know
how general like that is so we have
created a platform which was called
facebook announced just calling it the
common in which a doctor or a patient
can enter the specifics of the case on a
structured form which varies are a
little bit from cancer to campus and
then from that you can retrieve cases of
similar to patients who have had similar
cases and how they were treated and we
get from the finger boards with the
rationale for those treatments worth as
well as other hypotheses that was
considered if there's only a few cases
like yours or like mutation then you can
look through them
generalize that way if there's you know
a hundred cases in a similar or
potential development then we need to
have a way to visualize those and for
doing last we've creating the product
called kempton maps which you can think
of as a wave for cancer wave2 driving
application they just like dislike ways
those for traffic where your journey is
informed by the experience of motorists
or a few miles down the road for you we
are here with Captain maps is to have
your captain journey informed by the
experience of deflation for a few miles
down the road metaphorically speaking
from ruin their cancer journey and
what's nice about a visual
representation like this is that over
time it can be enhanced so that you can
overlay it with data as for example how
many patients in this way which is that
way and what the results were so we can
even or color code we can put the
thickness of the lines representing how
many patients and the color codes in
terms of green setting the yellow a
citizen red and capture maps we are
useful in another way which is as a way
to organize the information of schools
for example my presented a living at
work so we can take you know specific I
value content curated and associated
with a decision noted in the patient or
a position that a given node trying to
make a decision can be able to find for
example case reports or clinical trial
results or the blog postings of the
patients were actually on a given trial
or relevant literature in these articles
that are relevant in making that
decision so we believe this is something
that's much more helpful in terms of
getting a snapshot of what's going on
and then what we do is we ask patients
and doctors some useless information to
report back to what they did and how it
works but we continually update these
maps and more time and that's not the
learning was the primary room and will
happen when a patient is at the edge of
this map and unknown what they should do
that's when they can come and
cancer coming so ask em to comment is
the name of the service that I was
talking about a few flags act when the
patient comes chaos of a sub case and by
the way we buy we've now handled about
2,000 cases across all dentures which is
you know a fair amount but just a drop
in the bucket so you've got to do a lot
better and one thing to capture natural
what a few is being able to have an
answer that will we can give quickly to
the majority of patients and then if
they have remaining questions about some
greater is and that doesn't apply to me
or I'm not the edge with you like you to
then allow them at that point to use the
app counter common service to fill in
layers to the map and when people come
to us at this point we can refer them to
a clinical trial or to a particular
tumor board has unique expertise in
their cancer we're even to a researcher
who has been studying those cancers and
may have something in the back room that
could be very helpful to legislation and
this could be ethical tribe because the
patient is dying anyway and this is
something that clearing house counter
common seems very interested in
connecting patients with researchers to
their mutual advantage and I'll have an
example waiter in the stock subside when
some actual cases in which this has
happened so once we get the
recommendation from once we get the
recommendation back from these people we
will take those insights and put some
tentatively some tentatively on the map
so notice he's going to death and the
idea here is that this is provisional
and people will be able to see what
these recommendations were from the pea
top to avoid but without having the
strength of evidence is might ordinarily
have seeing coming from the experts on
some data and then what happens is that
these can be validated by additional
patients we will try them and report
back and all the time
they will become you know more
established parts of the map so over
time initial trails will harden into
highways and then super highways and
just like ways this learning process
will will one so what we're doing we're
best cancer Commons and maps is also
2,000 patients today with the maps maybe
we get up to ten to 20,000 patients a
year using we ask service to only show
in knowledge at the margins at the edges
of the map but what we need to do now is
to be able to couple in all of the other
people who are treating people patients
without beyond the standard of care and
get them to contribute their cases and
their knowledge to this learning
networks and that's our goal over the
rest of this year which is to find some
eggs Molecular to reward so they're
interested in working with us and we
have about a dozen or so who have
already indicated and this any of you
run fingerboards and would likely be
part of the Learning Network we would
welcome the opportunity to talk to you
but there was any cases to take the
cases from all of these and put them
into that case the church so that anyone
involved in this network can search for
you know cases that are similar to the
patient's who's having a challenging
cancers and be able to confer with their
colleagues amorous cases and thereby
accelerating now I want to say that this
is going by itself going to be I've been
tremendously helpful in accelerating the
search serve under a validation of
promising off-label and combinational
treatments however it's not by itself
enough to efficiently search the search
this space because this space has as you
know for himself and there's only a
million patients so when AI people come
up with these very large search places
as you would see in a programming in a
game of so for example the NAI program
to speak the world master that's not
done by exotic insertion to say it's
done by making a good guess of where the
search searching that area and what it's
working out but since Kieffer and if
it's not jumping to a different place so
we need to
perspectively there are an air traffic
control system so to speak across this
network so that we're not just capturing
the cases but we're active with
coordinating the search involving
different organizations so that
something for example is working for a
patient in the ass domain that and
there's a suitable patients who present
also in the network that we can probe
respectively and co actively recommend
this as a potential treatment so that
there's a kind of rapid replication and
similarly if something's not looking to
try to rapidly quash it before everyone
keeps going down the same rabbit hole as
often happens for years with therapies
that are known by some people not to
work but not yet by everyone the great
sexual manipulation to get footing into
that so collect capturing the cases of
step one and then putting an air traffic
control system on top of it the
coordinated all is where we're headed
and next thing to take us into the next
part of the talks which is the vision so
I'll get back and talk more about that
air traffic control system but first
things I want to say some something to
not wear the field as a whole head this
part of the talk has been well
documented in nature the newspaper that
I lived with my colleague Jeff Schrager
back in 2014 and if any of you would
like to follow up buying guide recommend
you to it we pay per talk about two
things we've talked about precision
oncology three-point goals which is the
next generation of precision ontology
and I'm going to talk about that in a
moment and you've also talked about
putting a layer of coordination on top
of that the technical term is global
cumulative treatment analysis and I'll
talk about that after I introduce
position ecology so you are no so this
is precision oncology 2 point 0 which is
what's happening guy as tumor boards
today and services like foundation
medicine and Matt house might provide so
patient was getting biopsied sequence
the sequences that the tumor and the
normal of being compared based on that
you choose a target look up
in the davidic knowledge base to find
out what treatments usually single
targeted therapies can be done typically
not too much testing that before you get
a syndication delivery awesome
chemosensitivity test the vindication
treated they're monitored you know a
couple months later with either scan
with some biomarkers and menaces
recurrence there's the big biopsies and
the second thing you can return and
position oncology 30 every single
service which is going to the improved
and this is happening it's in different
levels of different places today but
more places is doing all of these
progressions so let's go to them first
of all biopsy is being replaced by
multiple biopsy and specifically adding
liquid biopsy because of the realization
that captures so homogeneous and we're
seeing that you know results where
there's people are trying to compare the
results of molecular assays across
different commercial and with little
importance and many of us to leave the
major source of its importance is just
what heaven January of the tumors
themselves and even within member so
multiple biopsies sequencing is giving
way slowly to pan tomek so not not just
a genetic expression but copy member and
RNA expression RNA see gala efficiently
proteomics even metabolomics all of
these things are going to become
important as we move forward and then
what we should be simply comparing those
slashing genomes normal cell when I
count to selling the same patient will
be increasingly handled with
sophisticated computational systems
biology tools do network analysis and
which we can try to prune all of the
mutations and try to divide which ones
are actually relevant that would
behavior that we're observing and what
should be ingredient so that we can
approach a cancer at the level of side
hallmarks of cancer and try to decide
you know what combination of drugs needs
to be applied to knock out sleeve
hallmark should have got in this
particular tumor whether Leslie
uncontrolled growth or inability to stop
growth to put the brakes on or that
Zelda Frederick now I you of looking up
in that and I reports from foundation
medicine what I just look rugs are
indicated by itself is going to be
replaced increasingly by very
sophisticated she's been planning
informed by the network analysis and
typically involving either to the board
so the moral equivalence of them and
then we're going to see the hypothesized
tests being tested outside the patient
either in cell lines from that patients
are possible with potentially enough in
a pdx mouse model or maybe in the
not-too-distant future and in silico
models and back here and then the
treatments will almost invariably
combinations of therapies not single
therapy and finally increasing reliance
on serum market so for the rest of this
talk I'm going to be focused on this
particular area which is the increasing
importance of Informatics cancer
informatics I'll call it the
distinguishes from bioinformatics to say
which is specifically focused on trying
to take the results would be an ohmic
analysis gotta decide what's going on a
molecular level what we're talking about
here is taking the results of the
network analysis and trying to decide
what to do about it clinically which is
going to take into account facilitating
the all of the decision-making of the
extreme aboard as well as the
information that we can get folks like
whatever external tests can be done
before some unasyn
the patient this is not my slide it
comes from Denise wealth and folks
result of UC San Francisco who are
working on an ambitious plan to create
just such an automatic system and are a
little bit complicated for all take you
to it I do it because it's
representative of the kinds of
informatics of it being developed by
advanced in the boards around the
country in one form or another so in
this particular case a stage for
patients on the left presents they get
biopsy and their case is presented to a
molecular killer board which made for
treatment decision informed by two
things first of all the results of
next-generation sequencing and the near
case microenvironment profiling of the
human micro environment as well as a
bayesian prediction model which is based
on the preview and responses of previous
patient so you have these two things
informing the tumor boards and in
addition they even have some of this
external tested over quickly on the
response prediction engine is in fact
informed by cancer registry in their
case you see why or beyond and the model
also there there the model also includes
integrating this f of the external
effects of demographic to cell line to
be able to inform the decision the finer
thing is to close the loop so based on
this patient extruded the results go
into the registry and on the registry
our place and that will help inform the
treatment of the next patient similarly
if the patient doesn't respond it's back
to the drawing board and pre biopsy the
tissue so which is their nation and what
they are working on and another slide
that comes from their deck in a list of
a half a dozen or so other program which
there's a collaborated with that have
similar
than delivering all of which are
different so in that context let me go
back to the slides which I showed you
previously where so we have to do air
traffic control over this and overlay on
it and icon to indicate the different
bayesian decision mentions that people
are experimenting with and developing
some of these might even be just human
so the doctor the to the board
integrating in their minds the knowledge
shows what's going on too so again our
goal is to be able to integrate all of
the treatments and outcomes and
rationale and read that to try to
coordinate across all these things so if
something is working it can be rapidly
replicated when the similar patient
presents elsewhere and it is not working
you can be quickly flushed there are two
important without going into the
technical details that you can find in
the nature reviews paper there are two
important things that go on this level
which are novel the first is that it's
not clear what the best sensitive if
there's an echo koi situation then the
right thing to do is to select a therapy
that is going to maximize learning for
the system as a whole so which is the
key idea that turns all of this is the
kind of an extended registry file so all
things being equal if we if we know if
the patient's is a clear best thing to
do or the doctor or a patient has a
strong preference then ethics they
compel us to do that however in
equipoise situation which had more
common than you might think the system
can help create can help people achieve
the things that are going to maximize
learning so if everyone doesn't keep
trying the same thing that happens too
often income bracket in order to
maximize learning of course if the
patient is not responding on one of
those branches and we can quickly get
them back on blog notice acidosis that
you get by having everything
prospectively time together the other
important thing is if there are no good
choices at all then the patient is
referred to this very seat
a sequence that I've previously referred
to this position on college increased
windows so air traffic control to
coordinate everything together with two
really importance of novel animations in
equipoise situation to be able to
randomize which Isis with a bayesian die
so that's the things are the more likely
to work we're going to get oil it up
number one hand and on the other hand
could be able to compete science on that
patient but again on the time frame is
why couldn't you something for that
patient if we do all of these things I
think there's a very good chance that
you can significantly improve the
survival of today's patients who would
otherwise die but because they're not
getting the best care available there's
down you know in one of those other
places in Europe which is not a thing as
a mobile Sweden but also because we can
rapidly move the bar got the best care
for everybody by learning to optimize
the use of the drug to already have so
you know I think it's quite clear that
no one knows the optimal use melanoma
goes if we could optimize that we could
raise be born significantly so that's
what we're trying to give you the
informatics systems that we have here
not invent new guns per se but to
optimize with those people already have
okay what are the roadblocks for doing
this at a systemic level and they're
laid out here and I think everyone's I
everyone will know what these are you
know the widespread reluctant to people
to share data being able to access to
the investigational drugs that will
needs to be able to act on the
recommendations that are tumor board
often getting access to various kinds of
services and there's all kinds of
molecular diagnostic services which are
not even widely known much less how to
get a hold of them while different
institutions have access to the concern
successfully you buy for her approved
drugs to be able to use them in
off-label ways those reimbursement
issues
and then there's regulatory policy which
makes it more difficult than it should
be to be able to test new test existing
drugs as well as the drugs in
experimental cocktails where they were
strong rationale you know raising
rational hypotheses that informed those
kinds of Sherman so catcher comments is
trying to be an effort on the part of
everyone to step forward and helps us
solve these issues collectively because
no organization consultees alone in
terms of data sharing we are working
groups a number of the national health
services in Europe they try to put
together a consortium that will pour
this data with proper consent so that it
can be used in a collectible images and
the agreement was talking to the
Netherlands Belgium and Scotland are you
know some of the smaller systems in
Europe but collectively 155,000 patients
are something like three times as large
as anything that we can do in the united
states which are laid out here so being
able to get access to these stations
properly consented and the data in the
pristine form that i collected with NHS
and then work with you know pharma
companies and testing companies to put
in a molecular learning loop of the time
we [ __ ] it up in europe is something
that we're hoping can be jump started
and then we send to the US so number one
access to services this is really same
picture I useful decision ontology 30
and what I've done until I ran out of
safe was put down some of the many
hundreds of companies that are relevant
to each of the segments of this diagram
everything from very well known places
like foundation medicine to ones of you
main Eric never refer those such as
notable lab which is doing signal
sensitivity testing in a novel way for
the Athenia patients
I work in Silicon Valley and within 25
miles of where i'm sitting there are no
got many hundreds if not thousands of
something you could have interesting
things that can be applied for so you
help I informed cancer decision and if
you think about this country as a whole
it's a very large number it's a
completely dysfunctional market picture
no one knows these companies even it is
much less how to use them we want to
make this a rational marketplace for the
directory where people position I'm
scientists can very quickly find access
to the tests that are relevant to them
and basically doing 1-click ordering my
background in e-commerce to be able to
order those sets and then be able to get
the data back into the system so that it
especially the outcomes data so there is
some benefit everyone in the community
as a whole can learn so an example here
of what we're trying to do with an
industry Alliance but we're in the
process of putting together I can
combine both the function of a
marketplace and the data network is we
will refer patients being vetted
services that's any position that can
help them especially for those who have
agreed to make the data available in the
common bag and then we will turn the
round to aggregate that data and make
big treatment and outcomes available to
everybody who can use it for their own
purposes whether it's validating a
biomarker for figuring out how to treat
the next patient or actually go
companies reposition the judge on the
problem
how to get access to drugs and rhyming
attendees at the moment is a site that
goes on between any patients who want to
get access to a particular drug or their
physician and the impaired who is often
be elected to approve a drug that has
been studied off label and we take the
physician-patient fair and I think
there's a simple model that can be used
by put the separatists Rama and I'm
certainly open to other suggestions but
this is an example of what might be
might be done to align get everyone the
log of the same direction imagine a
situation in which the position applies
for compassionate views on the basis of
some compelling rationale is might come
out of the information with by capturing
from the tumor board on a meditation the
drug company on the basis of that
rationale agrees to provide me God get
no cost and frankly in most cases they
cost of the powder it's not going to be
a major extensively intellectual
property we're going to getting the
information that makes that out or a
drug Augustus where all the value is so
it's not going to cost them much to put
that up the guy's the drug works then
the patient's insurer should pay for it
is a contract that says Greg care for
that patient is covered and the jug
works drug companies should be
reimbursed so this is contingent
reimbursement something the practice
that happens people in Europe but
doesn't happen too frequently me life I
think that should be more commonplace
and then you know it's a joke doesn't
work then no the patients I can be moved
on to the next line of therapy but no
littlest lost you know the drug company
might be out the cost of some pills but
will have for years you know finding out
in you know an exhaustive laboratory
experiment succeeds it works with the
thing doesn't work invasion and in the
end you know if it does work they'll get
a little vacation so which is something
that i think the line everyone can chip
so rather the position the patient
researchers found
these Diagnostics companies and so forth
finally on regulatory reform I'd like to
point out that the amazing breakthrough
in aids back and HIV drug center am 1997
which happens with the creation of the
cocktail what many of you might not know
is what's immediately proceeded when the
gear to before the cocktail pain worse
there was a change in licensing at the
LCA but only for HIV AIDS drugs which
said that least once would be approved
not on the basis of the standard safety
and efficacy of the basis of safety and
bioactivity some of you may have seen
the dallas buyers club movie in which
patients you know I were both lamenting
that they wouldn't have access to the
drugs that were you know the early
coordination abusive should not very
good drug so you good provide you know a
monthly too aggressive and in the
absence of anything else vacation
squealing this we got this and the DOTA
this is all we have to go through big
thing and that web team this one more
real I think hiv/aids are the only good
but it can be licensed on the basis of
safety and by activities not neglect so
once they were licensed when the doctors
have them in the circuit and could begin
experimenting the de facto and I
strongly believe that cancer drugs need
to be licensed in the same way so that
they're available the doctors who can
combine drugs that might otherwise never
pass when we get close because they're
not efficacious by themselves but they
may very well be just what's needed to
make a cocktail work and didn't survive
so all these things that we talked about
us roadblocks are something that no one
organization can do we have to come
together there's a lot of Industry
alliances that none that I'm aware of we
are dressing in on the problems that are
needed in order to be able to solve
those roadblocks and in general promote
the widespread about
position oncology while accelerating the
acquisition is not working everything we
do with every patient is treated
continuous learning I also frankly leave
the debt by industry involved directly
in the country found in pursuing in
order to be able to accomplish at the
time agree and so improve that end we
can find a set of value propositions and
everything I've talked about is on the
slide and as you know benefits to
specific community certainly the count 2
comments network and the cancer map sort
of interest to physicians and patients
and that's important because this will
educate everyone about the value of
position ontology which is something
every company in the field needs because
so many people are way under tested for
molecular markers in various times it
might be influential in treatment pharma
companies will be very interested in
streamlined I'm trial enrollment and
making use of will sag air traffic
control as an alternative to position
ourselves to be able to very rapidly
replicate nf1 successes and turn them to
the case series which may be enough by
the way to be able to get reimbursement
because the number of companies world
including Medicare will reimburse
published a series which can be put
together much quicker by being able to
you know have a registry discuss across
multiple facts to be able to get
probation so we need to delegate the
creation of a bag of a diagnostics
market place actually being a great
interest not just the positions of the
companies themselves and have these
services so that people will be able to
order them from the very same knowledge
system the casebook that we talked about
that we're using some research cases oh
baby what you need to do Sofia so
station is like the Latian tears that
you assess so you can get the system and
of course getting having a source of
real war about some and cost data it's
very important both to be able to figure
out which treatments of cost effective
and to be able to validate fireboxes
everybody needs that and the NHS
initiatives I talked about it's a year
term source so in terms of people come
and become charter members of this
winter to the line these are the things
that they'll get right away get cancer
maps which will educate patients access
to this data and we registry and the
beginnings of the knowledge base so that
I went like when I go through some
takeaways and then open the floor
destruction so just what I hope you take
away from today the first that the
levers are testing
give you some takeaways that hopefully
will give you a different way of
thinking whether you're a doctor or
scientist or whether you're in Computer
Sciences for that matter the best of
which should just be important how
important it is to have information and
informatics the role that it can play
and transforming human health so that's
not to say that we don't need new cancer
drug or people understanding of counsel
or new biomarkers all the things of
course important but we already have
hundreds of drugs you know thousands of
Junction and routinely used for
Chancellor overall and thousands of
biomarkers papers over here and we need
to find a way to be able to optimally
use the ones that we already have
because unless we can solve that problem
having the thousand and first cancer
drug for bioinformatics or biomarker
it's not going to make a profound
difference you know one reads one is
going to give a patient you know one
more line of therapy after they've
exhausted their for Pfizer they already
have so unless we can solve the problem
of optimizing overall drugs and that's
this is an information problem it's just
a question of trying to figure out a way
to capture the knowledge that's in the
heads of many different people and bring
it together so that we get a whole as a
society and learning how to optimize
what we already have so that's number
one number two is that and then this is
based on this assumption that no one
today mostly optimization use any drugs
or even how to find out and that's the
guard of the limitations that we talked
about about clinical trials if there are
far more plausible regimens of drugs in
the used and I'm talking here about you
know the half dozen the show drugs with
one might use for a patient out of a
thousand it might be totally available
in what order in what dosing and when to
start going to stop and so forth no one
knows how to do this within files
because it's far more hypotheses success
than the rotation and inferring
the big data is like retrospectively
looking back and sure you can infer how
things have been used but not how they
should be it has to be done
prospectively action passivity studies
we turn to our experts in order to be
able to capture the knowledge of hid
their head they've integrated everything
that is is known and are in a position
to suggest the hypotheses they may be
right they may not be right that's why
it's important to close the loop and
validate and don't be within an
optimally efficient fashion and that's
where we're talking about in the Baptist
aging process that can optimize the
treatment decision for each and every
patient based on all the patients that
are has come before them and the results
of the stations immediately inform the
anticipation to contracts and given the
wide variation in outcome so we've seen
both in the US and across here I think
it's a very successful weekend it's not
moving in pure specifically extend the
lives of many many thousands of patients
a significant fraction of today's
translation by optimizing the use of
current drugs even without inventing new
guns and of course of food drugs get
created to the extent that we can
rapidly integrate them into regimen so
that they're used optimally not a single
agent sent in the combination that's
cool and then the final one is in order
to be able to do any of these things
we've got to get everyone to disable
that use to be at the table and that
basically includes all of you and all of
your organization so i will run by
inviting me to please join me and
counter common and moving this agenda
forward and i love to hear from you and
also if you happen to know any any
patients someone in your family or
someone acquaintance who can benefit
from the kind of very deep precision
ontology food point though that was
talking about here and as you know in
immediately I I was most welcome
clearing some
the station see those that's what you
get for it thank you very much
thank you dr. Tannenbaum for that
informative presentation before we get
started on the question and answer
session I would like to remind our
audience how pacific questions you can
submit the questions by typing them in
the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
best Pentagon your first question is
much of your learning appear to be
focused on molecular tumor boards do you
explain why well
so we thought used to say that's where
the money is here I'll say that's where
the knowledge is these these are you
know often our best doctors at the most
elite institutions working on the most
challenging cases and in fact knowledge
which is locked up inside their heads
and once they start talking about it
discussing it they said that the perfect
opportunity to be able to elicit that
knowledge in a way that's pretty asian
to stick a probe in without imposing
anything extra on their work if they can
learn from that and get that knowledge
out for the world and be able then to be
able to wear most of the patients are
saying because the tumor boards don't
see that many patients okay a handful of
patients get it out to where where the
analogous and then be able to quickly
close the loop I'm inform everyone
especially the patients really knowledge
started of what we wearing this is a
good idea not a good idea that's the way
the system can learn an enclosed leg the
knowledge terms many times a year as
opposed to one seventy five or ten years
of the cake in traditional research
I'm so sorry we have run out of time for
a question and answer session um but any
questions that were not answered during
this presentation dr. Tannenbaum can
answer those be an email following the
presentation now before we go dr. tun
abang you have any final comments for
our audience I said at the end of my
thoughts i won when i start at the end
of my talk i'd like to you know
underscore which is first and foremost
if you know anyone who might be able to
use our health and get connected to our
experts you know for their benefit and
for the learning unit everyone else
might derive from it please have them
get in touch with us or visit the
website and if you would like more
information about the industry Alliance
and what that might mean to you as an
individual who has a vision of the
future position and policy and what to
divert forward or to accompany sit
outside come talk to me directly funky
thank you again to dr. Marty Tannenbaum
I would also like to thank our sponsors
average for making today's educational
webcast possible today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
May twenty-third 2017 you will receive
an email from laboratory news when this
webcast will be available for replay we
invite you to forward that announcement
your colleagues who may have missed
today's slides events thank you for
joining us and we hope to see you next
time goodbye
you